le manuel d'Épictète
parmi les choses qui existent certaines
dépendent de nous d'autres non de nous
dépendent la pensée l'impulsion le désir
la version bref tout ce en quoi c'est
nous qui agissons ne dépendent pas de
nous le corps l'argent la réputation les
charges publiques tout ça en quoi ce
n'est pas nous qui agissons
ce qui dépend de nous est libre
naturellement ne connaît ni obstacle ni
entrave ce qui n'en dépend pas est
faible
esclave exposé aux obstacles et nous est
étrangers
donc rappelle-toi que si tu tiens pour
libre ce qui est naturellement esclave
et pour un bien propre ce quitter
étranger tu vivras contrarié chaque
grille
tu en voudras aux hommes comme odieux
mais si tu ne juges tiens que ce qu'il
est vraiment et tout le reste étranger
jamais personne ne saura te contraindre
ni te barrer la route
tu ne t'en prendras à personne
n'accusera personne ne fera jamais rien
contre ton gré personne ne pourra te
faire de mal et tu n'auras pas d'ennemis
puisqu'on ne t'obligera jamais à rien
qui pour toi soit mauvais
à toi donc de rechercher des biens si
grands en gardant à l'esprit que une
fois lancé il ne faut pas se disperser
en oeuvrant chichement et dans toutes
les directions mais te donner tout
entier aux objectives choisis et
remettre le reste à plus tard mais si en
même temps tu vises le pouvoir et
l'argent tu risques d'échouer pour être
attaché à d'autres buts alors que seul
le premier peut assurer liberté et
bonheur
donc dès qu'une image viendra te
troubler l'esprit pense à te dire tu
n'es qu'image et non la réalité dont tu
as l'apparence puis examine là et
soumets là à l'épreuve des lois qui
règle ta vie avant tout voici cette
réalité dépend de toi ou non dépend pas
et si elle ne dépend pas de toi soit
prêt à dire cela ne me regarde pas
souviens-toi que le désir est tendu vers
son objet tandis que le but de la
version c'est de ne pas tomber dans ce
qu'on redoute si l'on est infortuné en
manquant l'objet de son désir on est
malheureux en tombant dans ce qu'on
voulait éviter donc si tu ne cherches à
fuir que ce qui est dépendant de toi et
contraire à la nature il ne t'arrivera
rien que tu aies voulu fuir mais si tu
cherches à éviter la maladie la mort ou
la misère tu sauras malheureux
supprime donc en toi tout aversion pour
ceux qui ne dépend pas de toi et c'est
ta version
reporte-la sur ce qui dépend de toi et
n'est pas en accord avec la nature
quant au désir pour le moment supprime
le complètement car si tu désires une
chose qui ne dépend pas de toi tu ne
pourras échouer sans compter que tu te
mettras dans l'impossibilité d'atteindre
ce qui est à t'apporter et qu'il est
plus sage de désirer
borne toi à suivre tes impulsions tes
répulsions mais fais-le avec légèreté de
façon non systématique et sans effort
excessif
pour tout objectif
te sert ou te plaît représentes toi bien
ce qu'il est en commençant par les
choses les plus petites
si tu aimes un pot de terre dis-toi
j'aime un peu de terre s'il se casse tu
n'en fera pas une maladie
en serrant dans tes bras ton enfant ou
ta femme dis toi j'embrasse un être
humain
Sylviane à mourir tu n'en sera pas
autrement bouleversé
quand tu te prépares à faire quoi que ce
soit représente toi bien de quoi il
s'agit si tu sors pour te baigner
rappelle-toi ce qui se passe au bain
public on vous éclabousse on vous
bouscule on vous injurie on vous vole
c'est plus sûrement que tu feras ce que
tu as à faire si tu t'es dit je vais
aller au bain et exercer ma liberté de
choisir en accord avec la nature
de même pour toutes les autres tâches
car ayant fait cela s'il arrive quelque
chose qui t'empêche de te baigner tu
auras la réponse toute prête je ne
voulais pas seulement me baigner mais
exercez ma liberté de choisir en accord
avec la nature
si je me mets en colère à cause de ce
qui m'arrive ce ne sera pas le cas
ce qui tourmente les hommes ce n'est pas
la réalité mais les opinions qu'il s'en
font ainsi la mort n'a rien de
redoutable
Socrate lui-même était de cet avis la
chose à craindre c'est l'opinion que la
mort est redoutable donc lorsque quelque
chose nous contrarie nous tourmente ou
nous chagrine n'en accusons personne
d'autre que nous-mêmes c'est à dire nos
opinions c'est la marque d'un petit
esprit de s'en prendre à autrui
lorsqu'il échoue dans ce qu'il a
entrepris celui qui exerce sur soi un
travail spirituel sans prendre à
soi-même
celui qui achèvera ce travail ne s'en
prendra ni à soi ni aux autres
ne te monte jamais la tête pour une
chose où Ton mérite n'est pas en cause
pas encore que ton cheval se monte la
tête en disant je suis beau mais que toi
tu sois fier de dire j'ai un beau cheval
rends-toi compte que ce qui t'excite
c'est le mérite de ton cheval qu'est-ce
qui est vraiment à toi l'usage que tu
fais de tes représentations toutes les
fois qu'il est conforme à la nature tu
peux être fier de toi pour le coup ce
dont tu seras fier viendra vraiment de
toi
pendant un voyage en bateau si le navire
jette l'encre et que tu mettes pieds à
terre pour aller chercher de l'eau tu
ramasseras en chemin ici un bigorneau là
un petit bulbe de plantes mais te faut
concentrer ta pensée sur le navire te
retourner sans cesse au cas où le pilote
appelle si l'appel il faut tout planter
là de peur d'être jeté à fond de cale et
ligoter comme du bétail
c'est pareil dans la vie si en guise de
bigorneaux on te donne une petite femme
ou un esclave il n'y a pas de mal à cela
mais quand le pilote appelle court vers
le navire et laisse tout sans te
retourner et si en plus tu n'es plus
tout jeune reste à proximité du navire
de peur de manquer l'appel
n'attend pas que les événements arrivent
comme tu le souhaites décide de vouloir
ce qui arrive et tu seras heureux
tu souffres trouve l'endurance ont
insultes trouve la patience en exerçant
ainsi tu ne seras plus le jouet de tes
représentations
ne dis jamais à propos de rien que tu
l'as perdu dis je l'ai rendu
ton enfant est mort tu la rendue ta
femme est morte tu l'as rendu
on m'a pris mon champ et bien ton chant
aussi tu l'as rendu
mais c'est un scélérat qui me l'a pris
que t'importe le moyen dont c'est servi
pour le reprendre celui qui te l'avait
donné en attendant le moment de le
rendre en revanche prends-en soin comme
d'une chose qui ne t'appartient pas
comme font les voyageurs dans une
auberge si tu veux faire des progrès
laisse tomber les réflexions du genre si
je néglige mes intérêts je n'aurais même
pas de quoi vivre si je ne suis pas
assez sévère avec mon esclave il me
servira mal mieux vaut mourir de faim
délivrer du chagrin et de la peur que
vivre dans l'abondance au milieu des
angoisses mieux vaut être mal servi par
son esclave comme malheureux
si tu veux progresser accepte de passer
pour un ignorant et un idiot dans tout
ce qui concerne les choses extérieures
n'essa jamais d'avoir l'air instruit si
certains ont bonne opinion de toi
méfie-toi tu dois savoir qu'il n'est pas
facile de suivre ce conjoint la nature
en s'attachant aux objets extérieurs si
tu poursuis l'un de ces objectifs il est
inévitable que tu négliges l'autre si tu
souhaites que tes enfants ta femme et
tes amis soient éternelles tu es un fou
car c'est vouloir que ce qui ne dépend
pas de toi en dépend de ce qui n'est pas
à toi t'appartiennent
de même si tu veux un serviteur sans
défaut tu es stupide puisque tu voudrais
que la médiocrité soit autre chose que
ce qu'elle est mais si tu veux atteindre
l'objet de tes désirs tu le peux
exerce-toi à ce qui est dans ton pouvoir
tout homme a pour mettre celui qui peut
lui apporter ou lui soustraire ce qu'il
désire ou ce qu'il craint que ceux qui
veulent être libres s'abstiennent donc
de vouloir ce qui ne dépend pas de seul
sinon inévitablement ils seront esclaves
souviens-toi de te comporter comme dans
un banquet quand le plat faisant le tour
des convives arrive devant toi dans la
main et sers-toi comme il convient s'il
te passe sous le nez n'insiste pas si
tarde ne louche pas de science à l'Ivan
mais attend qu'il arrive devant toi fais
de même pour les enfants pour une femme
pour les charges officielles pour
l'argent et un jour tu seras digne de
boire à la table des dieux mais si les
choses t'étant offerte tu t'abstiens
même d'y toucher dis jeter les yeux tu
seras digne non seulement de boire avec
les dieux mais de régner comme eux
c'est ainsi qu'on vécu Diogène Héraclite
et leur semblable c'est galant par là
ô Dieu et gagnant le renom divin
lorsque tu vois quelqu'un cela montait
sur son fils parti en exil ou parce
qu'il a perdu ses biens ne te laisse pas
aller à croire que ces événements font
son malheur ce qui cause du chagrin à
cet homme ce n'est pas ce qui lui arrive
sinon cela ferait le même effet à tel ou
tel mais l'opinion qu'il se fait de cet
événement cependant ne refuse pas de
t'associer raisonnablement à sa peine et
même aux besoins pleure avec lui prends
seulement garde de ne pas pleurer aussi
en toi même
souviens-toi que tu joues dans une pièce
qu'à choisir le metteur en scène courte
s'il l'a voulu courte longue s'il l'a
voulu longue
s'il te fait jouer le rôle d'un mendiant
joue-le de ton mieux et fait de même que
tu joues un boiteux un homme d'État ou
un simple particulier le choix du rôle
et l'affaire d'un autre
si un corbeau pousse un cri de mauvais
augure ne te laisse pas entraîner par
ton imagination
défini ce dont il s'agit et dis-toi rien
de ce qui est annoncé là ne me concerne
seulement ma petite carcasse ma petite
fortune ma petite réputation ma femme ou
mes enfants quant à moi pourvu que je le
veuille tous les présages me sont
favorables car quoi qu'il résulte de ce
signe il est dans mon pouvoir de faire
tourner la chose à mon profit tu peux
être invaincu si jamais tu n'engage de
lutte ou la victoire ne dépend pas de
toi
garde-toi d'estimer heureux un homme
choisit pour une charge officielle ou
très puissant ou jouissant pour une
raison ou une autre de l'estime public
en effet si l'essence du bien réside
dans ce qui dépend de nous il n'y a de
raison ni d'être jaloux ni d'être
envieux quant à toi ce n'est pas général
magistrat ou consulte que tu veux être
mais libre or pour y arriver il n'y a
qu'un chemin le mépris de ce qui ne
dépend pas de toi
souviens-toi que ce qui te cause du tort
ce n'est pas compte insulte ou qu'on te
frappe mais l'opinion que tu as qu'on te
fait du tort donc si quelqu'un t'a mis
en colère sache que c'est ton propre
jugement le responsable de ta colère
essaie de ne pas céder à la violence de
l'imagination car une fois que tu auras
examiné la chose tu sauras plus
facilement mettre de toi
que la mort l'exil et tout ce qui te
semble redoutable soit présent à tes
yeux tous les jours la mort surtout et
jamais tu n'auras de penser lâche ni de
désir immodéré citron désire te pousse
vers la philosophie prépare-toi à être
partout en but au moqueries et aux
sarcasmes à entendre dire voyez le nous
revenir en philosophe ou qu'est-ce qui
nous vaut se feront superbe mais toi
garde ton front de tous les jours tiens
en fermement aux conduites qui te semble
les meilleures conscient que c'est Dieu
qui t'a mis à ce poste et souviens-toi
que si tu restes constant dans ces
principes ceux qui au début se moquaient
de toi finiront par t'admirer tandis que
si tu ne te montre pas la hauteur on
rira de toi deux fois plus fort
s'il t'arrive un jour d'accorder du
poids aux objets extérieurs par désir de
plaire à quelqu'un sache que tu réduiras
un néon tes principes de vie borne toi
donc à être toujours philosophe mais si
tu tiens aussi à le paraître que ce soit
à tes propres yeux et tu en auras fait
assez ne te laisse pas décourager par
des réflexions du genre je vais vivre
sans honneur je ne serai qu'un zéro si
vivre sans honneur est un mal aucun mal
ne peut arriver par la faute d'autrui
rien de honteux non plus crois-tu qu'il
dépend de tes efforts d'être tiré au
sort comme magistrat invité à un banquet
pas du tout alors comment sera sain
déshonneur de ne pas l'être comment
peux-tu dire que tu n'es qu'un zéro
puisque tu n'es tenu d'être quelque
chose qu'on regarde ce qui dépend de toi
domaine où tu peux prétendre au plus
grand honneur tes amis resteraient son
secours comment cela il ne recevrait pas
de tes mains leur petite pièce tu ne les
ferais pas nommer citoyens romain qui te
dit que ces choses-là dépendent de toi
et te regarde
qui peut donner à autrui ce qu'il n'a
pas lui-même
alors procure le toit dira-t-on pour
nous en faire profiter si je peux me le
procurer sans déchoirs à mes propres
yeux en restant loyal et sans bassesse
qu'on me montre le chemin
j'y vais mais si l'on veut que je perde
mes biens propres pour vous procurer des
choses qui ne sont pas des biens
considérés comme vous êtes injuste et un
gras et puis qu'est-ce que vous aimez le
mieux de l'argent ou un ami loyal et
digne d'estime et des mois à être tel au
lieu de vouloir que j'agisse d'une façon
qui me ferait cesser de l'être mais
dis-tu ma patrie resterait sans secours
quand je pourrais l'aider
là encore de quelle aide par le tue tu
ne peux lui offrir ni terme ni portique
et alors
le forgeron lui offre-t-il des
chaussures le cordonnier des armes il
suffit à chacun d'accomplir sa tâche
en travaillant à fabriquer pour elle un
citoyen de plus plein de loyauté et de
respect de soi ne ferais-tu rien pour
elle si fait donc tu peux par toi-même
lui être utile
quelle place aurais-je dans la cité
celle où tu pourras rester loyal et
digne d'estime mais si vous n'en servir
la batterie tu réduis un néant ces
vertus une fois perdu toute loyauté et
tout respect de toi quel service
pourrais-tu lui rendre pour un festin un
discours un conseil on t'a préféré
quelqu'un d'autre si ce sont des biens
réjou toi qui lui échoie si ce sont des
mots ne te plains pas d'y avoir échappé
d'ailleurs souviens-toi aussi que si tu
n'en fais pas autant que d'autres pour
obtenir ce qui ne dépend pas de toi tu
ne peux pas t'attendre au même résultat
que si tu ne vas pas rendre visite aux
gens qui comptent comment pourrais-tu
être récompensé comme ceux qui courent
comment c'est une flatte personne
obtenir autant que les flatteurs
tu as refusé de payer le prix de ses
faveurs et tu voudrais qu'on te les
accorde pour rien
tu es injuste et insatiable
combien coûte une laitue une obole plus
ou moins suppose que quelqu'un donne une
obole pour une laitue tu ne donnes rien
et ne reçois rien ne considère pas avoir
eu moins que lui il a sa laitue toi le
bol que tu n'as pas donné et bien là
encore c'est la même chose on t'a pas
invité à un festin c'est que tu n'as pas
donné le prix auquel on estimait le
repas et ce prix c'était flatterie ou
service donc si cela te sert donne-t-on
du quel que soit le prix mais si tu veux
être payé de retour sans rien donner tu
n'es qu'un insatiable et un fou
nature rien obtenu à la place de ce
repas si l'honneur de n'avoir pas flatté
qui tu ne voulais pas de n'avoir pas eu
à supporter la morgue des serviteurs
devant sa porte
l'expérience commune nous sert à
comprendre ce que veut la nature ainsi
quand le jeune esclave du voisin casse
une coupe nous sommes prêts à dire ce
sont des choses qui arrivent
sache donc que si c'est une de tes
coupes qu'on a cassé tu dois avoir la
même réaction que pour celle du voisin
applique cette règle aux choses les plus
graves quelqu'un perd son enfant sa
femme chacun de dire nous sommes tous
mortels mais si l'on est soi-même frappé
par un deuil on s'écrit aussitôt hélas
pauvre de moi
nous devrions avoir à l'esprit la
réaction que nous avons eu en apprenant
la nouvelle à propos de quelqu'un
d'autre
de même que la marque n'est pas là pour
faire rater la cible de même il n'y a
pas de place pour le mal dans l'ordre
universel
si on livrait ton corps au premier venu
tu serais indigné
et pourtant tu livres à n'importe qui
ton jugement avec pouvoir dit jeter
trouble et confusion pour peu
contingurie et tu n'as pas honte
pour tout ce que tu entreprends examine
les tenants et aboutissants avant de
passer à l'action sans cela tu sauras
d'abord plein de zèle parce que tu ne
penseras à rien de ce qui va s'en suivre
et puis dès que surgirons les
difficultés tu abandonneras lâchement la
partie tu aimerais être vainqueur aux
Jeux Olympiques moi aussi par les dieux
gagner au jeu c'est bien agréable mais
avant de te lancer examinez un peu les
tenants et aboutissants
l'abstinence sexuelle le régime le
renoncement au friandises les exercices
sous la contrainte et aux heures
réglementaires qu'on cuise ou qu'il gèle
il ne faut pas boire frais dans certains
cas même pas de vin sans remettre
entièrement à son entraîneur comme un
médecin
ensuite en luttant piétiner dans la
poussière au coude à coude avec son
adversaire parfois se démettre un
poignet cet ordre la cheville et
peut-être recevoir le fouet pour
finalement être vaincu
pense à tout cela et après si tu en as
encore envie entre dans la carrière
sinon tu ne seras qu'un gamin qui joue
tantôt lutteur tantôt gladiateur tantôt
au sonneur de trompette
tantôt aux acteurs de tragédie un jour
tu sauras athlète un autre gladiateur un
autre raiteur un autre philosophe mais
jamais tu ne seras rien à fond comme un
singe tu imiteras tout ce que tu vois et
tu choisiras tantôt une chose tantôt
l'autre car tu ne te seras pas mis à la
tâche après réflexion en ayant fait le
tour de la question mais au petit
bonheur
poussé par une éphémère en vie
c'est ainsi que d'aucun en voyant un
philosophe en l'entendant parler comme
Frat et pourtant qui pourrait se vanter
de parler comme lui veulent aussitôt se
lancer dans la philosophie mais mon
brave il faut d'abord examiner ce dont
il s'agit bien observer ton caractère
pour voir si tu pourras tenir tu as
envie d'être champion aux pentathlon ou
à la lutte regarde tes biceps tes
cuisses tes reins
nous ne sommes pas tous doués pour les
mêmes choses
crois-tu en te mettant à la philosophie
que tu pourras boire et manger comme à
présent CDAT tes désirs et te laisser
emporter par la colère comme à présent
il te faudra veiller souffrir quitter
tes proches
entouré le mépris d'un petit esclave
être tourné en dérision par les passants
et toujours avoir le dessous qu'il
s'agisse d'honneur officiels du pouvoir
de procès ou d'autres affaires de même
farine
voilà ce qu'il te faut examiner
sauras-tu prêt alors à payer de ce prix
l'insensibilité aux émotions la liberté
la sérénité si c'est long ne va pas plus
loin ne sois pas comme les enfants
philosophe un jour percepteur des impôts
le lendemain et puis raiteur et puis
encore procurateur de César tout cela ne
fait pas bon ménage il faut que tu sois
un bon ou mauvais il te faut cultiver ou
bien la part qui dirige ton âme ou alors
tu es bien matériel
consacrer tes efforts au dedans ou au
dehors c'est à dire régler ta vie en
philosophe ou en homme ordinaire
la plupart du temps notre conduite se
mesure à l'aune de nos relations
celui-ci est mon père je dois prendre
soin de lui lui céder en tout supporter
ses injures ses coups mais c'est un
mauvais père et bien la nature ne t'a
pas fixé pour rôle de vivre avec un bon
père mais avec un père
de même si tu considères un mâle ou un
bien ce qui ne dépend pas de toi si tu
ne peux obtenir ce que tu voulais ou
s'il te échoua ce que tu voulais éviter
tu t'en prendras aux responsables et tu
leur en voudras car la nature fait que
tout être vivant cherche à éviter et à
fuir les événements qui lui semblent
nuisibles ainsi que les causes qui les
déterminent tandis qu'il accueille avec
gratitude les événements conformes à son
intérêt avec ce qu'il est cause il est
donc impossible quand on se croit les
œufs d'être bien disposé envers l'auteur
de ce tort supposé tout comme on ne
saurait se réjouir du dommage lui-même
voilà pourquoi on voit des fils injurier
leur père quand celui-ci refuse de leur
donner une part de ce qu'il considère
comme des biens et de même ce qui
adressait Étéocle contre pollinis c'est
de croire que la tyrannie était un bien
c'est pour la même raison que le paysan
blasphème le nom des dieux comme le
marin le marchand et ceux qui ont perdu
leurs femmes ou leurs enfants car là où
est l'intérêt là et la piété en sorte
que si l'on s'attache à diriger ses
désirs et ses aversions comme il
convient du même coup on sera assuré de
se conduire avec piété pour ce qui
concerne les libations et les sacrifices
odieux il convient d'agir suivant les
traditions de son pays en état de pureté
sans négligence ni oubli mais sans excès
de minutie non plus et sans dépasser ses
moyens
quand tu as recours à la divination
souviens-toi que puisque tu es venu
trouver le devin pour qu'il te la prenne
tu ignores ce qui doit arriver mais une
fois l'événement prévu pour ce qui est
de sa nature tu la connais si tu es
vraiment philosophe s'il s'agit de
quelque chose qui ne dépend pas de toi
ce ne saurait être ni un bien ni un mal
donc quand tu vas voir un devin laisse
derrière toi désire et aversion ne
t'avance pas en tremblant mais en homme
pénétrer de cette vérité que tout ce qui
peut arriver est indifférent et ne te
concerne en rien
alors quel que soit l'événement tu seras
en mesure d'y faire face comme il
convient et sans que personne ne puisse
en empêcher donc n'est pas peur va vers
les dieux comme on va demander un
conseil pour le reste une fois le
Conseil reçu note bien qui était ton
conseiller note à qui tu désobéirais si
tu t'écartais de son avis
suit le précepte de Socrate le recours à
la divination quand des circonstances ou
tout porte sur l'issue d'un événement
quand ni le raisonnement ni aucun art
d'une autre sorte ne peuvent plus être
d'aucun secours pour connaître ce qui
t'attend par conséquent s'il te faut
risquer ta vie pour un ami ou pour la
patrie ne demande pas aux devins si tu
dois le faire si tu annoncé que les
présages sont mauvais il est clair que
cela signifierait la mort ou une
quelconque mutilation ou encore l'exil
ici la raison commande même dans ces
circonstances de prêter secours à son
ami et de risquer sa vie pour la patrie
pense au plus grand des devins l'oracle
de Delphes qui jeta hors du temple
l'homme qui avait choisi de ne pas se
courir son ami
à partir d'aujourd'hui décide d'un style
d'un genre de vie que tu garderas aussi
bien seul que devant les autres la
plupart du temps tais-toi ou si tu veux
parler à ton dis à être contraint et
fait le en peu de mots
exceptionnellement quand l'occasion d'y
convie parle mais ne t'occupe pas de
l'actualité combat de gladiateurs course
de chevaux jeu du stade nourriture et
boissons ici ou ailleurs tient ta langue
et surtout pas de réflexion sur les gens
en bien ou en mal ni de comparaison
aiguille autant que faire se peut les
conversations de ceux avec qui tu te
trouves sur des sujets convenables si tu
te trouves seul au milieu de gens que tu
ne connais pas tais-toi encore
rire rarement et pas à tout propos ni à
gorge déployée abstiens-toi de prêter
serment sinon en toute occasion du moins
chaque fois que c'est possible laisse
tomber les invitations à dîner
officielles ou privées et si un jour les
circonstances justifient que tu t'y
rendes soit extrêmement attentif à ne
pas te laisser aller à la vulgarité car
si ton partenaire est plein de goût en
luttant avec lui même si tu étais propre
en arrivant tu en sortiras tout crotte
pour ce qui concerne le corps
soigne-le autant qu'il faut pour
répondre aux besoins nourriture boisson
vêtements un toit et des esclaves tout
ce qui est pour la galerie tout le luxe
rejette le quant au sexe dans la mesure
du possible garde-toi pur jusqu'au
mariage quand tu fais l'amour prends ta
part de ce qui est permis toutefois ne
devient pas bagel envers ceux qui se
livrent à la fornication ne te pose pas
en sensur de ces gens-là ne va pas non
plus proclamer partout que tu aies
continent si l'on te rapporte qu'un tel
a dit du mal de toi ne cherche pas à te
défendre de ses accusations mais réponse
simplement je vois qu'il ne connaissait
pas tous mes défauts
sinon il en aurait dit bien davantage
il n'est pas nécessaire d'aller souvent
au spectacle mais si un jour l'occasion
se présente fais voir à tous que c'est à
toi que va la préférence
applique-toi à vouloir que ce qui arrive
et que le meilleur gagne de cette façon
rien ne viendra te contrarier
défense absolue de crier de te moquer
d'un concurrent ou de te passionner
outre mesure une fois sorti ne discute
pas longuement de ce que tu viens de
voir toutes ces choses n'ont aucun
rapport avec ton progrès moral ce serait
la preuve que tu t'es passionné pour le
spectacle
ne va pas pour un oui ou pour un nom
écoutez des lectures publiques mais une
fois dans l'auditoire garde une attitude
à la fois digne tranquille et sans
provocation
s'il te faut rendre visite à quelqu'un
surtout s'il fait partie de ceux que
l'opinion publique place au sommet du
pouvoir demande-toi ce qu'aurait fait
Socrate ou Zénon à ta place et tu
n'auras plus le moindre doute sur la
conduite à tenir en cette circonstance
lorsque tu te rends chez un personnage
influent prévoit qu'il ne sera pas chez
lui qu'on te fermera la porte au nez en
la faisant claquer bien fort et compte
se souciera pas de toi le moins du monde
si malgré tout ton devoir te commande
d'insister vas-y et montre-toi à la
hauteur des circonstances mais ne te dis
jamais le jeu n'en valait pas la
chandelle c'est une réflexion vulgaire
et d'un esprit esclave des choses
extérieures
au cours de la conversation
abstiens-toi de tes tendres sur tes
actions passées sur les risques que tu
as pris car s'il était doux de te
remémorer les dangers que tu as couru le
récit de tes aventures n'a pas les mêmes
charmes pour les autres
évite également de faire rire car non
seulement cela peut facilement tomber
dans la vulgarité mais cela risque en
plus de faire abandonner à tes
interlocuteurs leur retenue envers toi
un autre terrain glissant c'est quand on
en vient à parler de choses obscènes
quand cela se produit si c'est possible
n'hésite pas à reprendre celui qui a
commencé sinon exprime au moins
clairement par ton silence ta rougeur et
ton air réprobateur que cette
conversation te déplaît quand il te
vient l'envie d'un plaisir comme pour
les autres sortes de représentation
prend garde de ne pas céder à sa
violence laisse reposer la chose et
accord de toi à un délai
songe à ces deux instants celui où tu
goûteras le plaisir et celui où après
avoir goûté tu en auras le regret est
insultera toi-même tout bas
oppose à cela la joie que tu éprouveras
et les louanges que tu t'adresseras si
tu t'abstiens si tu trouves opportun de
passer à l'acte fais attention de ne pas
succomber à la douceur agréable et
séduisante de la chose
imagine pour y résister combien
précieuses et la conscience d'avoir
remporté cette victoire là
lorsque tu en arrives à la conclusion
qu'il faut faire une chose fais-la et ne
cherche pas à ton cacher même si les
gens risquent d'en penser du mal car ou
bien tu as tort d'agir ainsi et il ne
fallait pas le faire ou bien tu as
raison et tu n'as pas à craindre les
reproches injustifiés de même que les
phrases il fait jour et il fait nuit ont
une grande valeur en tant que
proposition disjointe mais ne veulent
rien dire si on les joint de même
choisir la plus grosse part si c'est
valable du point de vue du corps quand
il s'agit de sociabilité dans un banquet
cela n'est pas bien
donc quand tu dînes avec quelqu'un nous
considère pas seulement la valeur des
plats pour le corps veille aussi à
respecter ton autre
si tu te lances dans une entreprise qui
dépasse tes forces non seulement tu te
conduis comme un idiot mais tu négliges
d'accomplir ce qui était dans tes
possibilités
tout comme tu fais attention en te
promenant à ne pas marcher sur un clou
et à ne pas te tordre la cheville fais
attention aussi à ne pas faire de mal à
ce qui dirige ton âme en gardant cette
nécessité à l'esprit au seuil de chaque
entreprise tu feras plus sûrement ce que
tu as à faire
le corps est pour chacun la mesure des
richesses comme le pied et celle de la
chaussure
tu t'en tiens à ce critère tu garderas
la mesure mais si tu vas au-delà tu
seras forcément entraîné comme du haut
d'une falaise pour la chaussure si tu
vas au-delà des besoins du pied tu la
voudras couverte d'or puis un temps
pourpre puis broder une fois qu'on a
passé la mesure il n'y a plus aucune
limite
dès qu'elles ont passé 14 ans les hommes
appellent les femmes maîtresse elle
voyant que leur unique intérêt est de
coucher avec eux commencent à se
maquiller et mettre en cet art toutes
leurs espérances il faut donc leur faire
comprendre que leur seul gloire est de
donner à tous l'image d'une vie réglée
et d'une âme pudique
c'est la marque d'un naturel débile que
de s'attarder aux choses du corps comme
de passer trop de temps à prendre de
l'exercice à manger à boire à faire ses
besoins à copuler tout cela il faut le
faire comme en passant c'est sur notre
jugement que nous devons porter toute
notre attention
face à quelqu'un qui te fait du tort par
sa conduite ou ses propos souviens-toi
que s'il agit ainsi c'est qu'il pense
avoir raison il ne lui est pas possible
de régler sa conduite sur ta façon de
penser c'est la sienne qui le guide et
si elle était Renée il se fait du tort à
soi-même en demeurant dans son erreur en
effet si une vérité complexe passe pour
un mensonge ce n'est pas la complexité
qui est en faute mais bien celui qui se
trompe en te fondant sur ce principe tu
garderas ton sang-froid face à ceux qui
t'insulte chaque fois tu n'auras qu'à te
dire c'est ce que lui pense
toute chose à deux poignets l'une permet
de la porter l'autre nom si ton frère te
fait du tort ne prend pas cela en te
disant qu'il te fait du tort c'est le
côté impossible à porter dis-toi plutôt
que c'est ton frère ton compagnon tu
prendras ainsi la chose du côté où on
peut la porter
il n'est pas logique de dire je suis
plus riche que toi donc je vaux mieux
que toi je parle mieux que toi donc je
vaux mieux que toi ce serait bien plus
logique de dire je suis plus riche que
toi donc ma fortune vaut mieux que la
tienne je parle mieux que toi donc mon
éloquence vaut mieux que la tienne car
tu n'es ni ta fortune ni ton éloquence
un tel cela vite ne dis pas qu'il se
lave mal mais qui se lave vite
si un autre boit beaucoup de vin ne le
traite pas d'ivrogne dis simplement
qu'il boit beaucoup
en effet de cette façon tu éviteras
devant ce que tu te représente d'un
objet de lui donner une autre
représentation
ou que tu te trouves ne te présente
jamais comme philosophe ne parle pas
longuement devant des profanes des
principes de la philosophie agit plutôt
suivant ses principes par exemple dans
un banquet ne dis pas comment on doit
manger mange seulement comme il faut
souviens-toi de Socrate il s'était si
bien débarrassé de tout envie de briller
que lorsqu'on venait le trouver pour se
faire présenter à des philosophes
c'était lui qui conduisait les gens tant
il lui était égal d'être méconnu si dans
une assemblée de propane la conversation
tombe sur un principe philosophique
d'une manière générale
abstiens-toi d'intervenir tu risquerais
fort de recracher des bribes de savoir
mal digérées
si un jour on te dit que tu ne sais rien
et que tu n'en ai pas mortifié sache que
tu es en bonne voie ce n'est pas en lui
mettant l'herbe sous le nez que les
moutons montrent au berger qu'ils ont
bien mangé c'est alors laine et à leur
lait qu'on s'en aperçoit après qu'ils
ont digéré leur nourriture et bien fait
de même ne va pas mettre sous le nez des
profanes les principes de la philosophie
fait leur envoi les effets quand tu les
as digéré
si tu te contentes de peu pour les
besoins du corps ne va pas en faire
parade si tu ne bois que de l'eau ne va
pas dire à tout propos je ne bois que de
l'eau
si un jour tu décides de t'entraîner à
supporter la douleur fais-le en privé et
non devant tout le monde
n'embrasse pas les statues
si tu as trop soif prends de l'eau
fraîche dans ta bouche et recrache la
sans rien dire à personne
attitude et caractère de l'homme
ordinaire il n'attend rien en bien ou en
mal de soi-même et tout des
circonstances extérieures
attitude et caractères du philosophe il
a ton tout en bien comme en mal de
soi-même
signe distinctif de l'homme en progrès
il ne blâme personne ne loue personne ne
reproche rien à personne
n'accuse personne il ne dit jamais rien
qui tente à faire croire qu'il sait
quelque chose ou qu'il est quelqu'un en
cas d'échec ou d'obstacles il ne s'en
prend qu'à soi-même s'il reçoit des
éloges il rit en secret de celui qui les
fait si on le critique il ne cherche pas
à se défendre il marche comme les
malades attentif à ne pas brusquer le
membre en voie de guérison tant qu'il
n'est pas cicatrisé
tout désire il l'a écarté de lui quant à
la version il est entraîné à en éprouvé
que pour ce qui tout en dépendant de lui
et contraire à la nature ces
inclinations quelles qu'en soi l'objet
sont modérés s'il passe pour stupide ou
ignorant il n'en accure en un mot le
seul ennemi qu'il est à redouter c'est
lui-même
si quelqu'un se vante de comprendre et
d'expliquer les écrits de crises dis-toi
que si crisible n'avait pas écrit dans
un style obscur celui-là n'aurait pas eu
de quoi se vanter mais moi qu'est-ce que
je cherche à connaître la nature afin de
la prendre pour guider je cherche donc
un homme qui puisse m'expliquer la
nature
j'entends dire que crazypp et cet homme
je vais le trouver et je ne comprends
rien à ces écrits je cherche alors
quelqu'un pour me les expliquer jusque
là rien qui mérite le respect quand j'ai
trouvé cette interprète il me faut me
conformer au principe énoncé
c'est cela qui mérite le respect mais si
c'est seulement l'explication de texte
que j'admire ne serait-ce pas plutôt que
philosophe devenu un grammairien qui
gloserait crissip au lieu d'Homère
il y aurait de quoi rougir si lorsqu'on
me dit apprends-moi à lire crisip je
n'étais pas en mesure de montrer une
conduite semblable et conforme à ses
écrits
une fois que tu t'es fixé des buts tu
dois t'y tenir comme à des lois qu'on ne
peut transgresser sans impiété et quoi
que l'on dise de toi n'y prête pas
attention cela ne te concerne plus
combien de temps encore vas-tu attendre
pour estimer digne des plus grands bien
et c'est c'est enfin d'enfreindre la
règle qui doit déterminer ta vie tu
connais les principes qui doivent fonder
ta réflexion c'est assez réfléchi quel
maître attendu à présent pour te
décharger sur lui du soin de ton progrès
moral tu n'as plus qu'un ans tu es un
homme mûr si désormais tu te montres
négligent si tu prends les choses à la
légère
continue à échafauder projet sur projet
en reculant sans cesse le jour où tu
devras enfin prendre soin de ta vie tu
ne feras aucun progrès et sans t'en
rendre compte tu finiras par vivre et
mourir comme un homme ordinaire
décide donc tout de suite de vivre en
adulte résolu à progresser que tout ce
qui te semble meilleur te soit une loi
incontournable en présence de quelques
tâches pénibles ou agréables glorieuses
ou honteuse dis-toi que tu dois te
lancer que les Jeux olympiques sont
ouverts quand tu ne peux plus
tergiverser et qu'en un seul jour une
seule action peut anéantir ou confirmer
ton progrès moral
c'est ainsi que se comporter Socrate qui
n'écoutait en toute circonstances que la
règle dictée par la raison pour toi même
si tu n'es pas encore Socrate vie au
moins en tes forçant de limiter
le premier domaine de la philosophie et
le plus indispensable c'est la mise en
pratique des principes comme par exemple
l'interdiction de mentir
le second concerne les démonstrations
pourquoi il ne faut pas mentir par
exemple
le troisième concerne l'établissement et
l'articulation de ces démonstrations ce
qui explique par exemple qu'on est en
présence d'une démonstration
ce que sont une démonstration une
déduction le vrai le faux par conséquent
le troisième domaine est indispensable
pour accéder au second comme le second
pour accéder au premier mais le plus
indispensable le terme de toute
recherche c'est le premier seulement
nous faisons tout à l'envers nous nous
attardons au troisième nous lui
consacrons tous nos efforts en oubliant
complètement le premier
voilà pourquoi nous mentons sans cesse
en étant prêt cependant à dégainer le
raisonnement qui prouve qu'il ne faut
pas mentir
en toute occasion rappelle-toi ces mots
emmène-moi aux Zeus et toi au destinée
où vous avez formé le vœu de me conduire
je vous suivrai sans peur
mais si par l'acheter je résiste je sais
qu'il faut vous obéir
l'homme qui sait dignement à la
nécessité on le nomme sage car il
connaît les secrets des dieux
et bien crie-t-on si c'est là la volonté
des dieux qu'il en soit ainsi
anitos et melitos peuvent me tuer
ils ne peuvent me nuire